[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered I'm Peter Lavelle
president Donald Trump has repeatedly
said the US will withdraw from Syria it
would seem he's the only one in his
administration backing this move his
Trump in charge of his own foreign
policy are john bolton and Mike Pompeo
actually running the show
[Music]
crosstalking Trump Syria policy I'm
joined by my guess Saba Mukhtar
in London he is a lawyer and an
independent political analyst as well as
an expert in Iraqi affairs in Damascus
we have a Maher Wyckoff he is founder
and director of Knossos an organization
expressing stakeholder opinion in Syria
and in the Middle East and in Norman we
crossed through joshua landis he is the
director of the center of Middle East
Studies at the University of Oklahoma
alright gentlemen cross cross talk about
rules in effect that means he can jump
in anytime you want and I always
appreciate it Joshua let me go to you
first in Norman I have a very simple
question but I don't think there's a
simple answer Trump's foreign policy is
befuddling frustrating to understand and
it seems quite fluid so what do you make
of his policy as his major foreign
policy advisors including the US
Secretary of State is essentially
contradicting their boss on their Middle
East tour go ahead Joshua well you're
absolutely right and and for Americans
it's just as confusing as it is for the
rest of the world because the foreign
policy elite really has come undone and
the way this this process is hammered
out has now been thrown into some chaos
because the president has taken charge
of the Syrian issue himself and that
started in December 14th when the Turks
escalated they threatened to invade and
were bombarding northern Syria
this forced an escalation beyond the
sort of the top State Department and
National Security Council people and the
president took a phone call to air21 at
which point he said we're pulling out
this was news to the foreign policy
elite who wanted to stay in Syria to
counter Iran and rollback Iran so that
through everything the chaos then they
immediately sort of rolled back or Trump
statements and now Tron's come on again
said we are going to leave and he's
gearing up for a national campaign in
2020 in which
he wants to promise the people that he's
gonna end these stupid Wars the way he
did for years you know several years ago
and and so we're at a crossroads here on
the Syrian policy and there is a lot of
confusion you know it's a you know it's
a it can be all nice and fine if Donald
Trump and his advisers want to have this
charade played out in public fine okay
Donald Trump is a person that easily
changes his mind or he says something
different contradicting himself that's
all nice and fine we're used to it but
the region is and the Turks don't know
how to react the Damascus government is
confused the Russians are confused the
Iranians confuse and lo and behold the
American people finally found out who
the Kurds are because of all of this so
it's just not the confusion in
Washington it's creating confusion all
through the region go ahead Sabah in
London well quite frankly I think the
American has never had a policy they
wanted to have a regime change in Syria
that's as far as they can think of
anything else after that I don't think
anybody knew on the American side they
have no idea about the the Kurdish
problem they don't know the differences
between the various Kurdish factors they
don't know anything about the so called
Isis and other Islamist terrorist groups
they don't know anything about the
Syrian free army but they they were they
are the power that has the power it has
the airplane it has the voice that can
make and it can threaten turkey and
they've actually did so a little while
ago when they imposed economic problems
for for Turkey so the confusion is right
from the outset the outset and at the
outset they wanted to change the regime
then they decided they want somebody
else to do that and then after that they
decided well it's been weakened enough
so let's leave it now as it is this is
the I think this is how I would describe
the American policy as far as the
administration is concerned you have a
president who is unique in the United
States of America where he is taking the
lead into things which he doesn't know
anything about it he keeps on telling
he's the only president that the
American public and the media is
counting the lies he is telling he says
one thing and he says another thing then
you have the right wingers within the
administration who know a little bit
where they want to go they know they are
against the Iranians they want to
support Israel they are against Assad
and probably they are against the
Russians this is how they view it so of
course you have this confusion but at
the end of the day I don't think the
Syrian issue has changed from the
beginning until now
I said continuing to kill the people and
the people want to revolt against it
okay what's good in Damascus Omar I
think you know I'm sure you read Mike
Pompeo Cairo speech is one of the most
bizarre things I've ever read in my life
I'm not sure what region he's talking
around the world but it certainly wasn't
the Middle East okay and it was for the
most part about three things Iran Iran
and Iran it's it's really quite puzzling
to try to understand what that foreign
policy from the White House and from the
State Department what direction they
really want to go to really and he did
not address many important issues the
Palestinians Khashoggi calling the saudi
arabia to live the Iranians to live up
to the human rights standards of Saudi
Arabia what is going on with this
administration go ahead in Damascus well
the the point of the well the fact of
the matter is that the United States
will always be seeking more influence
and more stable and strategic influence
in the Middle East they are currently
threatened by some Russian expansion
because of the American policy in Syria
which you know created the circumstances
for a Russian increased influence in the
region now very traditional allies of
the United States very established
allies are not only talking more to
Russia but they're also having all these
even weaponry like in the Turkish
example so the in in the case of Iran
the United States probably think
that having Iran as a sole enemy would
gather as much allies on underway on one
front along with the United States as
much as possible
definitely Israel would be interested in
any American anti-iran policy in the
region the Saudis would the bulk of the
Gulf states probably apart from Qatar at
the moment Turkey would traditionally be
in competition with Iran and so on and
so forth so this is not new this has
been happening all along but we need to
understand that what is going on at the
moment is that probably some people in
the United States and definitely a lot
of people in Israel are thinking this is
the right time to pass or to make some
progress on the what we can call perhaps
the Zionist project so let us push any
anti Zionist project sentiment as
possible towards despair and let's make
good of any alliance with some Arab
states against Iran and turn around into
an enemy and the United States with some
lobbying inside the administration would
probably want that to happen but at the
end of the day the the the main issue is
that the United States feels that its
influence may be dwindling a little bit
its allies traditional allies may be
looking eastwards at the moment towards
the likes of Russia and China on that
point I would definitely agree with you
here Joshua the issue between the United
States and Turkey in northern Syria visa
vie the Kurds has not been resolved in
this I really fault American media and
Western media in general they don't look
at the other actors and the other
players in all of this because air Dewan
has really bet a lot on seeing his
policy to come to fruition and if he
doesn't know what the u.s. is going to
do once it understood it understands
where the United States or what the
United States wants to do then it can
act and everyone is not a man known for
his patience go ahead Joshua well you're
absolutely right
the Kurdish problem it turns out to be a
problem for everybody nobody really
knows what to do with it not America not
Turkey not Syria not Iraq and and this
is you know when the collapse of the
Syrian central state during the Civil
War Assad in many ways handed off
Eastern northeastern Syria to the Kurds
and to the YPG and then America which
had been helping the Arab militias
against Assad hoping to overthrow the
regime put in a pro-american regime that
would make peace with Israel this
completely collapsed and so the United
States was left siding with the Kurds to
fight Isis these this virulent Sidney
telephone group that was trying to build
this big Caliphate and that that caused
in a sense the United States to side
with allies of Assad if you would but
now they're withdrawing everybody is no
none of the regional powers want there
to be an independent or autonomous
Kurdish entity with its own military and
that is a very difficult problem for the
United States to get out because they
want to make sure that their allies
don't get completely smashed in the
process and okay so it's embarrassing
let me say I almost got a clear break
Josh and let me stay with you here but I
understand that the various Kurdish
groups are in negotiations with Damascus
right now to come to some kind of
resolution as if and when the United
States leaves go ahead Josh oh you
finish up before we go to the break this
puts the United States in a very
embarrassing position because it means
that if the Kurds and Damascus patch up
their relations form a and agreement
over bringing a Syrian army back in to
this whole northern region which would
be the best thing for the Kurds it is
gonna embarrass the United States
because then to fight against Isis and
continue the war counterterrorism war in
the East the United States effectively
has to work with Assad because the YPG
will become part of the Syrian army
and and that puts the United States back
at square one of reconciling with the
Assad regime even if it's distasteful to
them and working with it effectively and
that's where the United States stands
today as this entire revolution that it
promoted and as for the overthrow of
Assad in a sense it's discovered that
the alternative turned out to be
something worse Isis or al-qaeda or
other Islamic groups that the United
States didn't want to deal with and now
it's back to square one
okay I'm gonna jump in here gentlemen
we're gonna go to a short break and
after that short break we'll continue
our discussion on Syria stay with our
key welcome back to crosstalk where all
things are considered on Peter labelled
to remind you were discussing Syria
[Music]
okay let me go back to Saba in London
sup I couldn't help but notice when I
was asking questions of joshua landis
and norman there you were where i think
you were disagreeing
go ahead elaborate that's correct
it's the the Kurdish issue I think
everybody is relying on the Kurdish
issue as the main cause of all these
confusion and this is not true
the Turkish the Kurdish issue is a real
issue for the Turks but not for their
medical exam or even for the Syrians the
Turks as far as they're concerned this
is a domestic problem which they have to
resolve it America don't even understand
the difference between the various Kurds
whether they are in Iraq or in Syria or
in Turkey they don't know the movement
and they are willing to decide they have
a designer made Kurdish movement some of
them are good some of them are bad just
as much as they were doing with the
Islamist movement some of them are good
Muslims and some of them are bad Muslims
this is not the issue the issue is the
Americans started to change the regime
they decided not to because they can't
or for whatever reason the situation is
staying as it is the Turks are
determined they are not going to allow
the Kurdish problem to be an issue for
the national security of Turkey and they
are going to use force they are going to
use force even if the Americans stay
there the Americans have to get out for
a variety of reasons including money
because general Trump is being saying he
is he wants money he doesn't want
anything other than money he doesn't he
doesn't care about politics or
international or Middle East or anything
else he wants money from the regimes
from everybody else and he wants money
for his services that's what he's
telling the American people because he
cannot offer them what the American
people are expecting from him but on the
Sirians scene I think the situation is
as is it hasn't changed the Americans
are going to withdraw whether they are
slow or fast or whatever and the Turks
are not going to allow the Kurdish
movement to start a new country as
happened in the north of Iraq under the
watch of the Americans and this is where
the problem is
okay I'm on let's go back to Damascus
limini it's interesting with Saba is
saying because John Bolton when he was
in Ankara was publicly humiliated when
air Dhawan refused to meet with him and
instead air21 took the time to address
the Turkish Parliament to basically
berate Bob Bolton I I think the Western
media coverage of this situation here
does grossly underestimate how Turkey
feels now I you know I don't believe
invading a foreign country saw a
sovereign country is right is a breaking
of the internet international law but
Saba is a very right the the the Kurds
matter not as some kind of political
trophy to pass around or give excuses
for it does matter to the Turks can you
think Damascus and the Kurds come to an
agreement where Turkish aggression can
be avoided go ahead in Damascus well we
don't think that Turkish aggression is
inevitable we need to remember that
turkey isn't working alone on this
they're working with Russia and Iran and
if we go back a few months to September
when they had you know a summit in
Tehran between Putin Hartigan and
rouhani they are a statement afterwards
in which they said that they refused
Americans changing the facts on the
ground under the pretext or umbrella of
fighting terrorism and that these three
states would work against this project
that basically threatens the integrity
and safety of the Syrian and unity of
the Syrian territory and at the same
time and this is the the most important
point I think here it's the national
security of neighboring countries and
this is a public statement they're not
you know they're a sort of commitment
has taken place so would Turkey coming
from that analogy would turkey go alone
in northern Syria without a consent from
Russia and actually behind the scenes
Damascus we don't think so but probably
all these parties if we think of them
now as a
Quartet Russia Iran Turkey and Damascus
Syria they're probably pushing the Kurds
two words or maneuvering the Kurds
towards lowering their demands when they
are talking with Damascus we think that
the Kurds do not really think an
autonomy is possible and Doc definitely
the Americans don't think the an
autonomy is possible in northeastern
Syria so probably what the Americans
wish out of this is to avoid a
humiliating situation when the Arabs
over there for example would be so
enraged with American presence think
about it as an occupation that they
would actually start attacking US
soldiers and be probably the United
States would want to withdraw swiftly so
that they create a vacuum that would
lead to conflict between those fourth
parties Iran Turkey Syria and Russia now
that that said the safe way out of this
will always be a negotiation with the
central government in Damascus what the
Kurds would come out would bring out of
that negotiation is yet to wait to see
that but hopefully it will be good for
all the parties okay well you know every
time there's a negotiation to end the
conflict in Syria the u.s. seems to
upset it maybe once once it does leave
it'll leave the the the players on the
ground because it they have real genuine
interests they can resolve it Joshua
it's been reported that in September
John Bolton went to the Pentagon and was
asking for a menu of ideas how to react
militarily to Iran for an alleged terror
attack within the Green Line in Baghdad
does that tell you everything we need to
know about John Bolton in the Middle
East well you know it's not only that
but John Bolton had been before he got
his present job he was he was lobbying
for regime change in Iraq he was talking
to regime change in Iran excuse me he
was he was talking to big Iranian groups
in United States and saying that he was
all in favor of regime change in Iran so
he isn't very aggressively anti-iranian
and which I presume is part of the
reason he was brought to the top of the
pick for President Trump so president
Trump is sitting on a very anti Iranian
foreign policy crowd and we say that
from Pompeo and his speech in Cairo is
you you explained in your opening which
was a really a love letter to Saudi
Arabia what exactly all the problems in
the Middle East on Iran and this is of
course a the anti Obama policy in some
ways but it's also it puts the United
States in a very small camp and it's a
camp that's very divided because the
Gulf Arabs and Israel which of course
America is trying to bring the two
together to face off against Iran
they're extremely divided and we see
between Qatar and Saudi Arabia but none
of the Gulf Arabs really trust each
other they're not ready to really
combine and it's it's a mess the Middle
East is a mess today and the United
States doesn't really know what to do
with it you know Sabah let's go back to
London I mean we when Trump made his
announcement the original announcement
in December of last year of withdrawing
from Syria it was quickly followed up by
lowering the number of troops in
Afghanistan after Trump made his trip to
Iraq not going through the diplomatic
procedures which obviously annoyed the
Iraqi government they - says said it's
time for American troops or some of them
to leave here I mean we do have an
exodus of one form or another and it's
all of these countries want American to
leave it's interesting to pompeius that
we only go where we're asked to go and
we leave when we're told to leave which
is patently untrue but there seems to be
a movement across this very large region
to see a lowering of American military
presence in different countries that
have different interests this seems to
be a trend and I think this is what the
foreign policy blob is terrified of
because it's this kind of this um
imperial role in the Middle East is the
glue that keeps the political class
together if it's
publican or Democrat they all seem to be
in lockstep on the dus you'd never leave
once it's gone somewhere go ahead Sabha
what do you see here in Britain when we
were the empire in that region we knew
how to run things that's the British not
me
the Americans are trying to do the same
thing but they have absolutely no idea
how to do this thing when I go to
America if I tell somebody I'm from them
then I have to say London England
because they think it's some sort of a
village in one of the Wyoming state or
they have they have no idea about that
region now the present moment the
regimes that are in the Gulf in Jordan
in Egypt and precisely in Iraq are all
protected by the Americans and Trump is
absolutely right in saying we are
protecting all of you and we are keeping
you there all of you this is absolutely
correct America never talks about Iraq
he has five thousand soldiers in Iraq
that's Trump he talks about Syria he
talks about Afghanistan he but he never
talks about Iraq because under the
pretext that he is fighting Iran he is
keeping the American soldiers to protect
the regime in Baghdad which is pro Iran
which is a conflict of nobody can
understand this idiocy of policies but
as far as the American policy America no
longer has friends other than Israel and
even in Israel they are beginning
because because of trumps loose stock
every time he talks from the hip and he
keeps on sending these tweets and he
annoys everybody even the Israelis are
getting annoyed with it he has no
friends in the Middle East nobody trusts
him anywhere not even MBs who has given
him half a billion or half a trillion
dollars of investment even he doesn't
trust them anymore
okay so the almost out of time and I
want to go back to Damascus Amari what's
really interesting again it's
underreported in Western media is that
essentially as Syria has been welcome
back and
the Arab League Gulf countries are
moving opening up their embassies here I
mean it there is a wide acceptance now
in the region that they the government
in Assad will stand and remain go ahead
in Damascus yes I think a lot of people
in the region and probably in the West
as well we've heard for example from
Britain Foreign Secretary Jeremy Hunt
saying the same we have to expect
President Assad to be there for a while
and we have to work on that and they
congratulated Russia for winning a
sphere of influence in Syria and they
thought that this comes with some
responsibilities and so on but visitor
via the Arabs it's also a little bit
more complicated than what it seems
perhaps the likes or the axis now we can
we can probably talk about an axis of
Saudi Arabia UAE Egypt Bahrain they took
the first step they took the initiative
to renew relationships with Damascus and
bring back the maskers to the Arab fold
the UAE was the first to open its
embassy there the Saudis are ok Omar
embrace I have to jump in here giving we
are run out of interest okay thanks to
my guests in London Damascus and in
Norman and thanks to our viewers for
watching us here at RT see you next time
and remember frost on walls
[Music]
you